uh hi i'm daniel kane i'll be talking
about sq lower bounds for learning half
spaces with massage noise this is joint
okay sorry yeah sorry
a few more minutes because
okay great so now we're ready so we'll
have daniel kane presenting espy lord
balance for massage voice
yeah uh hi i'm daniel kane uh this is
joint work with elias diana colas who
was just speaking um he talked about
this general non-gaussian component
analysis problem and sq lower bounds and
said there were a bunch of applications
to more specific problems and this is
sort of
uh an overview of the kinds of work that
you have to do to to adapt uh
this framework to get lower bounds for
your problem
um
so
uh the basic topic of this is learning
half spaces so
for this we define a linear threshold
function or an ltf this is a boolean
function on rtd given by f of x is sine
of v dot x minus t so you take x you
evaluate this linear
function and you determine whether it's
positive or negative
and the basic problem that we're going
to be looking for is that of learning
linear threshold functions so
there's some unknown distribution d on
arc d and some unknown linear threshold
function f
you're given samples x y where x comes
from the distribution d and y is equal
to f x and you'd like to learn a
hypothesis h such that the probability
that h of x is not equal to f x is say
less than epsilon
and when you put it this way this is
actually reasonably well known it's been
known for some time that you can solve
this problem in something like
polynomial and d over epsilon time and
samples um and you know this is you know
these results are pretty well
established these days
um but things become a little bit more
complicated when you talk about noise
and it's somewhat unrealistic to assume
that your data is 100 accurate i mean
maybe there's some small amount of model
misspecification where like the correct
model to be looking at uh
isn't quite a linear threshold function
it's you know a little bit off or there
might just be some kind of errors that
show up where some small fraction of the
time you there's noise in your data you
don't get the correct x or value or the
correct y value and there's
some small probability that y is not
equal to f of x
and the question is what kinds of
learning are still possible
uh under these kinds of assumptions
and before we get into any details of
this we first need to ask the question
what noise model should we be
considering here
and so there are a few to look at the
maybe the most natural is that of
agnostic noise where you allow for
basically arbitrary but uncommon errors
now you need to be a little bit careful
about how you define this question
because you can no longer hope to
perfectly recover the function f
because an adversary adding errors could
just add errors so that instead of
seeing y equal to f x you see y equal to
f prime of x where f prime is some
nearby threshold
uh and so generally the way this gets
phrased is you define you you let d be
some distribution on r to the d cross
plus minus one
and you let opt be the probability that
f of x is not equal to y so this is
basically the the the smallest error
that you can achieve with any linear
threshold function
and now given these samples x y from d
you want to learn a hypothesis h such
the probability h of x is not equal to y
is less than opt plus epsilon
and the merits of defining it this way
is that that
given that you you don't need to do
better than up this is at least
information theoretically possible
and in practice ops plus epsilon is is
often too much to ask for so sometimes
we'll settle for you know olive off plus
epsilon or even polyoptic plus epsilon
but generally we want something that you
know liar goes to zero reasonably
quickly as opt goes to zero
and unfortunately for linear threshold
functions this might be too much to ask
so there's a result by the yelli from
about five years ago that says uh under
some plausible hardness assumptions
about random kx or problems there is no
polynomial time algorithm that
distinguishes between on the one hand
the case where opt is exponentially
small and say log d to the 0.99
and on the other hand the case where opt
is only slightly less than a half
and
on the one hand this means that it's
actually impossible in polynomial time
under these assumptions to get error
much better than a half
even if opt is
is this small almost polynomially small
in the dimension d
i'll also say that this result you can
pretty easily use its techniques to get
sq lower bounds with very similar
looking parameters
and what this says to us is that we
can't really care only about polynomial
time algorithms that the agnostic noise
model is perhaps too hard we can't
really expect to get very much out of it
so we'd like to look at an easier noise
model
and maybe the the easiest noise model to
look at is random noise
so if we have a sample with random
classification noise at a rate theta
what this means is that we sample x
according to d
and then we set y equal to f of x with
probability one minus eta and minus f of
x with probability and so
basically each point we are randomly and
independently flipping the value of y
with probability
and fortunately random classification
noise you can also deal with so it's
been known for for some time that even
with random classification noise you can
learn the linear threshold function to
error eta plus epsilon in again
polynomial samples in time
and eta plus epsilon maybe doesn't sound
so good until you notice that that is
the same as opt plus epsilon in this
case because every sample gets corrupt
with probability eta uh there's no hope
of getting a empirical error less than
eta just because
that's that's the noise rate
and it's a little bit instructed to look
at the proof
and one way of proving this is that
random classification noise behaves very
well with respect to statistical query
algorithms
in particular if you've got some test
function g what is the expectation of g
of x y where y comes with this random
classification
well there's a one minus eight of
probability that y is equal to f of x
and then you just get the sort of
expectation of g of x y with no noise
and there's an eta probability that that
you flip to y and you get the
expectation of g of x comma minus y with
noise
now
if you sort of combine these together i
mean
what you get basically is that
well if you if you given any function h
we can try and find a function g such
that these two equations hold for all x
and then this you can solve for g just
using uh linear algebra
and then if you plug this into the above
formula you'll note that the expectation
of g of x y with random classification
noise
is the same as the expectation of h of x
y
without any noise
and the point is that
by sort of making the noise cancel out
you can simulate noiseless statistical
queries even with random classification
noise in the samples that you see
and in particular since there are
statistical query algorithms for
learning half spaces um you just use
those you use this to reduce to the
statistics query algorithms and then
you're done
and to me
this algorithm suggests that random
classification noise is actually not a
very good model it's somehow too
predictable uh it there are good
algorithms in the model but they depend
on being able to make the noise exactly
cancel out in these expectations
and
my intuition says that in most real
world situations those algorithms will
not work
because the noise is not going to be so
predictable that you can get it to
cancel out in this way
for example we might expect in real
world problems some examples say maybe
examples very far from the decision
boundary
will almost never be misclassified
whereas examples very close to the
decision boundary might be misclassified
with much higher probability
now it might not sound like having some
examples having a having a lower
probability of misclassification will
make things harder
but it would actually mess up these
particular algorithms that were used
and so this suggests at least to me that
we need a better noise model than random
classification noise if we want to
understand real problems
so a step up from this is what's known
as massage noise
so a sample with massage noise at some
rate here what you do is you sample x
from your distribution d as before
always
and then there's some function eta of x
that's point wise bounded by air
and you let y equal f of x with
probability y minus eta of x and minus f
of x with probability a of x
so this is almost the same as the
definition of random classification
except
that the noise rate is allowed to depend
on x
the samples they still have you know
independent probabilities of being
flipped but the probability of flipping
the value of y is allowed to depend on
the value of x as long as it's still
point wise bounded by this number
and it was an open question for a while
whether you could
learn with respect to this massage noise
and a couple of years ago um
ilius and a couple of his other
co-authors resolve this that that you
can learn a linear threshold function
with the start noise to error eta plus
epsilon and poly d over epsilon samples
in time which is great
now this result looks very similar to
the result that we had for random
classification isn't so we might think
that we're done
but we're not
because for random classification noise
opt is equal to eta
like you're you've got ada noise
everywhere and so you cannot expect to
learn to error better than ada plus
epsilon in fact if you learn to error
ada plus epsilon that means you've
actually learned the sort of noiseless
function to error something like epsilon
however for massage noise the optimal
error might be much much smaller than
either eta is now just a point wise
upper bound on our error rates it might
be the case that with high probability
over x there is no noise on y and maybe
only with very very tiny probabilities
does the noise rate approach anything
close to
and so
the real question now is you know can we
do better we learn maybe to error opt
plus epsilon
now that has been known for
not very long but for a little while to
be impossible there's a recent result
that says there's uh
no sq algorithm with polynomial accuracy
and queries that can learn a linear
threshold function with the start noise
error opt plus the little o of one for
all values of optimization
now this says oppose epsilon isn't
possible but it's still not great it
doesn't answer you know maybe we could
learn error
or poly-opt or maybe
this can work for certain values of
optimato or something like that
and the general question that we'd like
to answer
is when you're learning half spaces with
massart noise
what is the best error rate that can be
obtained that you can learn too
efficiently
as a function of both opt
so i give you i give you some some
problem i promise you that often ada are
going to be these particular values what
is the best area that you can hope to
learn too efficiently
and unfortunately the main result here
is that the situation is still not great
so the theorem that we prove is that
there's no polynomial query and accuracy
statistical query algorithm that learns
a linear threshold function which may
start noise at rate say eta equals a
third so constant error rate
um to error better than one in polylog
of the dimension
even when you are guaranteed opt is
you know exponentially small and log d
to the point nine nine
so things to know firstly the opt here
that we have is comparable to danielle's
results which was in the much much sort
of worse agnostic noise model
however the achievable error that we
have is worse even in these hard
examples it's possible to learn to error
one in polylog now we know from the
upper bounds that there will always be
like we can't do as well as danielle's
result where you can't learn to error
much better than half because it is
possible to learn to error ada plus
epsilon but it would be nice if the
actual bound that we had was
closer to that
okay so that's the result that we're
going to try and prove and so the rest
of this talk is going to be sort of
about how do we prove that
and for this we should recall from
elias's talk how do you prove sq lower
bound so um there's this non-gaussian
component analysis problem if you have a
distribution a that matches k moments
and he's he used m i'm using k slight
difference with a standard gaussian then
an sq algorithm that distinguishes
between the standard gaussian and this
sort of
thing that's the a in the v direction
and gaussian in the orthogonal
directions
either makes um you know queries of very
good accuracy or makes an exponential
number of graphs
uh now for our purposes we're going to
need to be able to deal with
distributions that don't quite exactly
match moments with the standard gaussian
but using basically the same techniques
you can show that if we only match
moments up to some error new we get the
same lower bounds except tau increases
by something like new square
now
the non-gaussian component analysis
technique is great for showing that it's
hard to learn distributions
but
our algorithm we're trying to learn
functions our algorithm sees this
distribution over pairs x y but y is
bernoulli y is a plus minus one random
variable there's no way we're going to
be able to fool a statistical query
algorithm into thinking that y is maybe
gaussian distributive when it's really
plus minus one and so instead of
tricking the algorithm to thinking that
the whole distribution over x y is
gaussian
what we're going to try and do is we're
going to try and forward to be making it
hard to distinguish between the
conditional distributions x conditioned
on y equals one and x conditioned on y
equals minus one we want both of those
to be hard to distinguish from gaussian
and it turns out that that's enough in
general
so the new lower bound is somewhat more
complicated we have two distributions a
and b on r they match k moments with the
standard gaussian to error new
for this new distribution we have a
probability p
and a unit vector v
we're going to let pv be the
distribution of r to the d cross plus
minus one
where with probability p
y is equal to one and
x is this p a v distribution
and with probability one minus p y is
equal to minus 1 and x is this pbv
distribution
so so here if you like fix y you've got
one of these non you know hidden
direction distributions that are hard to
distinguish
and the claim is that any sq algorithm
distinguishes this
from a standard gaussian cross an
independent y value where plus and minus
one come with these same probabilities p
and one minus p
again it either makes queries a very
good accuracy
or makes an exponential number of
equations
um
so
this is a lower bound if we want to
prove an sq lower round against learning
an ltf with massart noise all we need to
do is construct an example of this form
where p sub v is an ltf with massage
noise
how hard can that be
well unfortunately that doesn't actually
work
because you can show that any
distribution a which even approximately
matches say one in epsilon squared
moments with the gaussian
has the probability that a is bigger
than the threshold t
is equal to the probability that g
the gaussian is bigger than t plus o of
epsilon
and we actually can't afford for this to
happen for both
the conditional distribution of x on y
equals one and the conditional
distribution of x on y equals minus one
um if you look at the threshold then one
of the two of those at least needs to be
almost certainly less than d or almost
certainly bigger than t when the
gaussian isn't
and so
to solve this problem
we're going to need to
find another way of phrasing we're going
to need to produce this sort of
non-gaussian component analysis problem
that isn't itself an ltf
but corresponds to a linear threshold
function in some more complicated space
and the way we're going to do that is by
looking at polynomial threshold
functions
so a degree k polynomial threshold
function or ptf
is a function of the form f of x is sine
of p of x where p is some polynomial of
degree at most k
and the thing to note is that a
polynomial threshold function is just a
linear threshold function in the
monomials of x
more specifically if we define b sub k
or x to be the set of degree k monomials
x
in rn
then f of x
is equal to g
of v sub k of x for some linear
threshold function
and so in particular if we have some x
where some f where it's really hard to
learn
f
then equivalently there's this linear
threshold function g where it's really
hard to learn g
so in particular we need to show that
there's some that you cannot learn a
degree k polynomial threshold function
in
poly n poly polynomial in this the
dimension of this bigger space
polynomial in d to the k samples and
accuracy
because then this will give you this
higher dimensional ltfg that you can't
learn in polynomial
samples and accuracy in the dimension on
which g is defined
okay so how does this work
um so what does this distribution mean
well it needs this construction needs
two distributions a and b
for our sort of conditionals on y equals
one and y equals minus one
we also need
a degree k ptf and a degree k ptf in one
variable is basically just a union of k
over 2 so we need a and b and j which is
a union of k over 2 intervals
and they have to satisfy a bunch of
conditions
a and b need to approximately match many
moments with the standard gaussian in
fact they need to match more than k
moments because we need lower bounds to
be better than d to the k
furthermore we want op to be small
so all but opt of the mass of b should
be supported on j
and all but off to the mass of a should
be supported on j complement
finally we need this pair a and b to be
given by
this
appropriate polynomial threshold
function with massart noise
and that means that once we condition
online in
j the output should be you know
with probability at least two thirds
should be should give us y equals minus
one and when we're on j complement with
probably at least two thirds we should
get y equals one
um and what this sort of boils down to
is it says that b should be at least two
a on j
and a should be at least two b
on j complement
and there's a little bit of subtlety
here because we can really adjust this
parameter p sort of this um
uh all priori probability of seeing plus
one or minus one in the output of our
uh function and basically what this
means for this is that we a and b don't
have to be distributions with the same
normalization one of them can be
an unnormalized probability distribution
with total mass more than one
okay so we need to find a b and j with
these properties how do how the heck do
we do this
and the basic instruction comes from
this idea that we're going to let b be a
net of gaussians
so it's a mixture of gaussians they've
got
with epsilon and separation delta the
overall envelope they satisfy is some
bigger gaussian
and it's not hard to show this matches
in fact many many moments with the
standard gaussian to error approximately
e to the minus 1 and delta squared
now what's j going to be j is going to
be a union of k over two intervals
around sort of small integrals around
the peaks
of the k over two closest to the origin
of these gaussians
and it's not hard to build doesn't show
that all but something like p to the
minus delta k squared of the mass of b
is in j
okay so that's b what's a
we're going to start with a being just a
taller gauss sort of this unnormalized
thing
this matches moments exactly with a
gaussian which is great
and it is bigger than b on j complements
because we
made it bigger
the problem is that we need to fix this
so that a is smaller than b on j
and to do this
we've got a trick we're going to sort of
move the mass of a that is on j off of
it
and we're going to do this in a way
without changing any of the first m
moments
and the lemma here is that if you have a
distribution d on some interval
and you have a sort of sufficiently
small sub interval in the middle of it
there's a new distribution that's
supported on the original interval minus
the sub integral that matches m moments
with the original distribution
and
the proof here is
i mean it's
um it's not terribly complicated
basically what you do is remove that
little bit of probability mass and then
you
just have to modify the the
probability density function so that you
match these m moments again
and well basically you need to have an m
plus one parameter way in which you can
modify the probability density and
for that and then once you have that you
just sort of do some linear algebra to
make the moments match again um and
there are a bunch of details to get the
right parameters here um but the basic
idea is relatively simple
once we have that
uh we can just apply this modification
to a around each interval of j so each
interval of j is a tiny interval
we can modify a on some bigger interval
so that we move the mass off of j but
keep the moments the same so we have
some distribution here now a has no mass
on j
which is great
and um so just looking at the parameters
here um and this is the dimension of the
the underlying ltf this is d to the k so
k is approximately log n
we need that the that exponential of one
and delta squared this is the error to
which we match moments is bigger than
the complexity it has to be big much
bigger than m
so delta is going to be smaller than
about k to the minus a half
and opt the op that we get is like e to
the minus k delta squared which is about
e to the minus k which is almost inverse
polynomial in n
and finally epsilon this interval with
that we get
this is like has to be less than one and
m squared for this moment matching thing
to work and that means it has to be less
than about 1 in k squared
and this is a bit of a problem because
we need a to be taller than b off of j
and this means that the normalizations
of a and b need to differ
by something like delta over epsilon
and that means that this probability p
that like talks about the probability of
getting one versus minus one sort of a
priori in our distribution it's going to
be very unbalanced it can be unbalanced
by like epsilon over delta which is like
1 in poly log m
and that means that even though it's
hard to distinguish this family of
distributions from something where x is
independent of y
the y's that you're seeing are heavily
unbalanced you can just return a
constant hypothesis y
and only have error about one in polylog
now doing any better than that
will will break this thing do any better
than that will force you to distinguish
between being a distribution from this
family and being something where x is
independent of y and that therefore is
s2 hard so you can't learn to error
better than one in polylog of the
dimension but you can do that
uh efficiently
now there is a more recent refinement to
this technique uh that shows that it's
hard to get better than constant error
even with very small values upped um
that sort of uses some of the same tools
put together a little bit differently we
basically the constructions with a and b
is now slightly more efficient
um but yeah so in conclusion
uh you can learn
linear threshold functions with the
start noise the error ada plus epsilon
but you cannot hope to do much better
than that even if you are guaranteed
that the optimum is quite small
and more generally hopefully this is
given sort of a feel that the sq lower
bounds are a useful tool for getting
evidence of hardness for function
learning problems
now for this particular area further
work i mean it'd be nice on the one hand
to get similar results via uh reductions
from some
some sort of sort of standard heart
problem rather than results in this
restricted model of computation
um it would also be nice uh to sort of
extend these kinds of techniques to
lower bounds for learning other linear
models like values and there's
some difficulty doing some of that with
uh statistical query lower bounds
because
um
basically the the kinds of s two
dimension arguments that we are using
tend to only really work when the
distribution that you're working with
has full support
and here we were able to get away with
it because i mean y was plus minus one
value we have basically full support
it's fine
um but when you start looking at real
valued functions
they tend to be supported on some
measure zero set
and it's very hard to get sq lower
bounds to work in that context
um in any case um i'm probably a little
bit overtime but that's all i had to say
are there any questions
i guess one question is like for the
conference model do you hope to get even
stronger hardness results or this one's
already quite strong
i mean so the concrete error here
um
i mean already shows that you can't
learn to better than constant error even
if you have the audio with pseudocod
noise
um
i mean
it's not cold
for someone else
oh yeah so i mean it should already give
some sort of result there since subakov
is
uh some
uh some subset of masar
um
i'm not entirely sure what kind of
bounds you would want that are better
than that i mean for any parameters of
super cog noise
you can probably learn
well okay fine you you might hope to to
show that you can't turn to error better
than a half even with relatively weak
supercob parameters
um
but i guess we haven't looked into that
question
can you hear me
here yeah
can you go back to the
i mean well
i mean a constant
um you can get a little bit more precise
which says that that for any
for for
this constant i mean so this constant
holds when a equals a third in general
you can show omega of ada
okay that's what i wanted
yeah let's not go and break until 11 10
and
yeah
sound good